um a phenomenon that has happened again
i blame the past 30 40 years where you
know people give their entire lives to a
company and then get the proverbial gold
watch there's an entire generation that
when we talk about the gold watch they
don't know what we're talking about
uh because this doesn't exist anymore
and if you think about it
and again because of the the commonality
the frequency of of the use of layoffs
as a as a as a tool
right we all i'm for those who saw the
better.com video i don't know if you saw
it
it was embarrassing you know the ceo
made a video that he played to employees
that i resumed
so if what he fired 900 people 900
people with a video saying if you're
unlucky enough to be seeing this video
effectively perspective
you're terminated effective immediately
you know two weeks before christmas and
when the cfo was interviewed about it he
said well we need to and i love this
terminology we need to fortress the
balance sheet
this is why we should not let cfos like
talk to the public
early
our cfo is a wonderful man
give it up for pearly
[Applause]
we love you it's very rare you must it
must it must be great here because cfos
never get that kind of applause it's
really wonderful
um
uh
uh
but the point the point is is is um is
what he what he amplified
is that if you have your own business if
you're a small business owner
you know you're going to go out of
business
months before like no small business
owner goes to work the one day thinking
everything's fine then the next day
there's nothing it just doesn't exist
but we now live in a society where
having a stable job with benefits could
end
tomorrow
effective immediately is what they were
told not a meritocracy no fault of my
own the company's doing well
and so if you think about how twisted
that is that a quote unquote stable job
is actually not stable at all
and that stress
sits with every single employee you said
we need to have a meeting and fear is
the first reaction says something
not necessarily about the company but it
says something about business
and the way business and corporate
america is viewed